the Revolutionary Armed Forces of  Colombia FARC is the guerrilla  organization that the administration of  one Manuel Santos has negotiated a peace  agreement with the FARC dates back 52  years founded to wage an insurrection  against the democratic institutions of  Colombia attacking the oligarchic  political system and economic system  through the use of force in the  mid-1990s the FARC evolved into the  biggest cocaine smuggling organization  in the world and they used this to  generate revenue the FARC is not a  popular organization by any means  today they probably command less than  three or four percent of the vote the  question is with the opportunity to  establish a presence on the ground  unassailed  by the government will they build up  their base of popular support undermine  confidence in the democratic  institutions in the elected government  of Colombia which is South America's  oldest democracy